famille à oligarques et leurs hôtes pour
s'ouvre dans un spectacle sûrement le
plus dur passage que je réfléchisse à
des visions à faire du mentalisme et
nous sera d'ailleurs une démonstration
de chanter dans mentalist
là vous me voyez un peu plus en
difficulté que d'habitude c'est tout se
joue là c'est si je rate ce que je viens
de faire moi je joue pas ma carrière
mais je joue quand même à crédibilité
maintenant
salut il ya quinze jours j'ai été invité
en direct dans l'émission de laurent
ruquier léa salamé on est en direct
c'est une émission du soir à ces langues
ou plein de personnalités viennent de
parler de différents sujets parfois
faire leur promotion c'était mon cas et
il ya deux choses évidentes la première
chose c'est que c'est une super nouvelle
pour moi pour faire la promotion de mon
spectacle au zénith de paris donc c'est
très chouette c'est pas facile
d'atteindre des émissions de grande
envergure comme ça surtout quand on est
considéré comme youtube heures et que
parfois les gens ne regardent pas le
reste de ce que je fais à côté là ce
n'était pas le cas donc c'était cool et
la deuxième chose qui est évident c'est
qu'on allait me demander de faire
quelque chose en terme de mentalisme et
vous allez voir que je pouvais pas avoir
pires conditions que ce qui s'est passé
tout risquer tumeur on va vous allez
voir d'ailleurs comment ça s'est passé
ce n'était pas vraiment simple et
surtout je vais analyser ça à l'ancienne
et nous fera d'ailleurs
le porte parole du gouvernement étaient
là pour faire un discours et on avait
prévu qu'à la fin de ce discours moi je
fasse quelques commentaires comme les
analyses que je fais d'habitude avec
vous ça qui a motivé la locution sauf
que comme l'émission prend beaucoup de
retard et bien régulièrement on vient me
voir discrètement hors champ pour me
dire en fait l'analyse avec gabriella
talent on n'aura pas le temps de la
faire donc moi ça veut dire que je
l'écoutais pendant 25 minutes en
analysant sa demande de la concentration
en notant des choses sur un bout de
papier qu'il fallait que je passe au
real pour que le real puisse mettre les
images à l'écran de quand jade
intervenir tout ça ça saute
chaque fois sur un malentendu me siècle
là vous voyez je viens de boire un tout
petit peu d'eau parce que j'ai senti
qu'il allait conclure juste avant donc
je me dis ça va être à moi ne pas le
droit à l'erreur
vous avez entendu tout ce brouhaha on
n'a rien compris parce que en fait
isabelle thomas laurent les à jacques et
moi on a parlé en même temps c'est la
première fois en 2h15 des missions déjà
écoulé que tout le monde parle en même
temps que c'est inaudible pourquoi parce
que quand ils reviennent sur moi il
envoie un petit peu d'énergie et moi
j'essaie de renvoyer de l'énergie pour
réveiller tout le monde et pour le coup
ça les a réveillés et c'est un problème
c'est parce qu on est passé de sujets un
peu qui on rhône qui était sais pas qui
endorment mais qui sont un peu plus ou
comme ça à un sujet qui est un peu plus
atypiques et donc tout le monde s'est
réveillé à parler en même temps et l'âge
de six mois où je suis je suis foutu
cambrai
qualifier pour la coupe du monde
c'est énorme parce que là j'ai arrêté
sur une image où pour une fois c'est moi
qui suis très lisible sur le visage en
gros il reprend la parole pour parler
ici déjà qui va parler longtemps donc
avec son bras gauche il le pose sur mon
bras à moi c'est une forme de blocage en
fait non verbal de désolé mais j'ai
repris le bâton de parole et regarder
comment moi je le regarde je le regarde
si c'est pas du mépris parce que je pars
le menton haut ou quoi c'est plus de
l'acceptation un peu dépité
je regarde dans jacques je vous adore
mais mais du coup je suis foutu vous
venez de récupérer la parole pour je ne
sais pas combien de temps et l'émission
va se terminer et c'est drôle de voir ma
paie pas ce moment là vous êtes surtout
le mentaliste mentalist c'est à dire que
vous devinez et pourtant de déduire des
choses
par exemple
des choix il est le 11 décembre
2021 au zénith paris là vous voyez j'ai
le visage beaucoup plus détendue parce
que laurent ruquier en grand
professionnel a assuré quelque chose
c'est à dire c'est la promotion en fait
à ce moment là quand il fait la blague
il le fait pour la blague mais il le
fait aussi pour pour se dire le pauvre
il est là depuis trois heures maintenant
on sait pas combien de temps ça va ça va
durer pour lui si on aura le temps de
faire des choses avec lui donc au moins
je parle un coup de son spectacle vous
savez ça passe ça paraît peut-être rien
pour vous mais organiser un zénith de
paris en autoproduction comme ça m du
mentalist dans une salle comme ça c'est
une dinguerie et du coup c'était
important pour moi en fait qu'ils en
parlent à ce moment là et c'est des
trucs de mentalist donc parce que le
mentaliste est une branche de la magie à
la base
mais attention
vous avez vu ce que je fais avec mon
regard je regarde la sallaz mais je
reviens sur laurent ruquier je reviens
sur thomas vdb pourquoi parce que comme
je sens encore une fois la concentration
très fébrile il faut que je fasse des
liens au regard pour être sûr qu'il soit
sur moi qu'ils soient concentrés qu'ils
soient pas trop en fait dans leur tête
prêt à faire une blague ou un truc comme
ça
jacques vendroux pas trop parce que j'ai
peur que si je croise son regard ils
prennent ça comme une invitation à me
répondre dans ces cas là je serais fou
tu donc là je sens que j'ai un tout
petit peu de moments et que ces partis
quoi pour qu'elle ait pas ce qu'elle
doit acheter dans la liste des courses
et quoi comment on fait alors la
technique la plus simple pour pas
oublier ce qu'on doit acheter c'est de
faire une mise sur un bout de papier
c'est pas parce que
là vous me voyez un peu plus en
difficulté que d'habitude pourquoi ça
revient en fait à son parler je viens
ici à la base pour parler de mon
spectacle potentiellement de mentalisme
de spectacles donc des trucs plutôt
bluffant et le mon problème à ce moment
là c'est de me dire aïe aïe aïe si on me
demande des choses comme ça ça prend du
temps quand même a expliqué donc comment
je fais pour synthétiser au mieux
l'information ne pas être décevant quand
même en expliquant des techniques de
mémoire qui m'ont pris vous le savez des
fois des vidéos de 20 me trente minutes
à vous expliquer comment je fais passer
des messages comme ça en trente secondes
pour ne pas consommer le reste de mon
temps pour ça on utilise le palais
mental c'est le plus simple vous
imaginez dans votre chambre vous faites
un tour mentalement de toute votre
chambre la porte de l'armoire la table
de chevet le lit etc et donc vous n'avez
pas le mobilier par la suite dans le
magasin vous repensez votre chambre vous
allez revoir ses e set congédiant
pas très fun je veux dire
vous avez vu mon mouvement de recul qu
elle dit je m'excuse mais c'est pas très
fun et là je me suis au c'était purement
défensive de ma part de masse je pensais
pas me faire attaquer à ce moment là je
peux me faire attaquer sur plein de
choses mais à ce moment là c'était
c'était assez étonnant pour moi et je me
dis ou est ce qu'il veut en venir et là
il pose ses questions et on le voit je
la comprends pas très bien
[Rires]
c'est la fête c'est dur pour moi de
reprendre la main à ce moment là c'est
pas très fun c'est pas très fan c'est
pas très fun et le premier c'est pas
très fun ça fait quatre fois qu'ils
disent que ce que je fais ce que
j'explique dans la vie c'est pas très
fun c'est toujours très compliqué parce
que c'est comme si je vous dis ne pensez
pas un éléphant à ce moment précis vous
pensez un éléphant donc en fait le fait
qu'ils disent quelque chose comme ça en
boucle ça peut rentrer dans l'esprit des
gens autour et donner un mode différent
à mon passage
d'olivier mais ça d'où ça vient en 2007
vous avez vu comme laurent ruquier
déconcentrés ils en train de regarder à
droite à gauche d'avoir des petits rires
et au contraire la boule voyez sur mon
visage mois celle inverse c'est tout se
joue là on rigole on rigole il est une
heure du matin ça fait trois plantes
qu'on est là enfin trois heures
réellement si je rate ce que je viens de
faire c'est décevant au possible et
c'est quand même laurent wauquiez qui a
dit à l'ats une démonstration maintenant
sauf que moi je joue pas ma carrière
mais je joue quand même à crédibilité
maintenant
symbolisée ça aujourd'hui elle avec un
personnage imaginaire ok on va faire ça
ensemble laurent hilaire vous demander
de pense alors moi à ce moment-là ce que
je veux c'est qu'on crée un personnage
imaginaire et que laurent ruquier lui
attribue un signe astrologique ok donc
qui pense à un signe n'importe quel
signe astrologique mais un signe qui
correspond à quelqu'un qui connaît dans
la vraie vie par exemple ma mère est
scorpion donc c'est un peu ce que je
demande à laurent de faire de penser à
n'importe quel signe de n'importe qui
qui connaît et de la tribu est ce
personnage imaginaire quant à léa salamé
je vais lui demander de penser au prénom
de ce personnage imaginaire et je vais
essayer de déduire tout ça au fur et à
mesure avec mes astuces
c'est une femme peu importe laurent vous
allez penser ainsi là déjà laurent il a
regardé à gauche à droite je vois qu'il
veut être concentré mais je vois que
c'est la fin de soirée encore une fois
pour cette personne ne le dit pas mais
vous imaginez son signe astrologique
donc vous pensez vous pensé au prénom de
cette personne vous l'avez pas prononcé
jusque là donc vous allez visualiser ces
personnes et son prénom alors je vais
prendre de quoi noter vous avez lettre m
donc là moi je me dis ah y est c'est bon
les consignes sont claires laurent
ruquier pense à n'importe quel signe
astrologique dans sa tête à partir de
maintenant les à elle pense à n'importe
quel prénom à partir de maintenant je
peux déroulé naïf que je suis notre
lettre du prénom oui prenez notre lettre
encore comme ça c'est un petit peu
brasse et c'est aléatoire vous pensez à
cette lettre vous me regarder dans les
yeux vous ne cherchez pas donné d'avis
c'est peut-être bête a b c d e f g h i j
qu'elle émane au pq reste élevé w x y z
y xwb vitesse à plus haute énergie à
jeff des cvg quelque chose je vais voter
ici alors attention ça c'est un passage
délicat j'appelle le hic la gare près de
moi s'il vous plaît loïc en regardant
les mouvements mon crayon est ce que je
peux leur passé plusieurs fois est ce
que tu peux essayer de déduire ce que
j'écris comme latine lettres majuscules
mais je vais repasser plusieurs fois sur
le trait pour qu'elles soient écrits
bien grosse ce que il devait filmer
cette lettre ils ne l'ont pas le film
est donc comme j'avais peur qui le
filmait pas que je vois pas de caméra
derrière je vais la faire voir à jacques
il sera le seul à l'avoir
j'ai juste hâte et la lettre voyez à
l'avance comme ça je ne pourrai pas
changé après au fur et à mesure vous
allez pas
ouais ouais c'est un peu mais c'est ça
que tu entends aussi au sens a fait bon
ça nous servira plus tard voilà voilà
vous allez penser au prénom dans son
intégralité s'il vous plaît à imaginer
son prénom comme ça devant moi est ce
que vous pouvez me dire quel âge aurait
sept personnes fictives s'il vous plaît
tant de 40 ans autour de 40 ans d'accord
ok pense à son prénom et pelé le led
parlez dans votre tête première lettre
quatrième
regarder à 5 jusqu'à 5e le visage ou
c'est un truc de mentalisme jusqu'à la
5e fête son visage ne bouge pas du tout
je vais appuyer sur play et regarder si
je me souviens bien ça se passe juste
ici le relâchement qui veut dire qu'elle
arrête de passer des lettres dans sa
tête
vous avez vu et c'est comme ça que je le
dit et c'est terminé regardez pas ce que
je fais c'est vous pourrez regarder un
petit peu
alors vous rendez compte de ce qui vient
de se passer là la série dont il ya
thomas qui dit moi je suis claqué je
comprends à ce qui se passe laurent
wauquiez qui libère toi aussi thomas qui
dit quoi faudra dire waouh à la fin et
là laurent il balance une punch énorme
pour moi ils diffusent déjà en train
d'essayer de trouver un signe
astrologique et je me dis ce que la
actuellement il en a pas en tête parce
que vraiment il a eu le temps d'en
trouver un et je me dire ah là là on va
tout perdre et comme je les sens tous
fébriles en termes de concentration vous
avez vus à cette petite phrase là de
laurent qui dit ça va vous thomas je
sens que je perds tout le monde quoi à
part les acquis et j'avoue très très
concentré et c'est très cool du coup il
faut que faut que j'accélère le truc
avant afin que ça s'arrête et avant que
je foire tout et du coup je me dis pour
laurent b je veux lui donner a déjà un
bel actif ait avec avec les 12 signes
astrologiques dessus et comme ça ils
l'ont choisi au pif et puis c'est réglé
quoi sursauter vous avez tous fassent
des 12 signes astrologiques vous allez
choisir un signe dans votre tête accord
là comme ça ce sera le signe charnley
voilà soit visible vers le haut et vous
mettez votre main par au dessus pour le
cas chez lacan gros si vous pensez
rédaction mettez scorpions je regarde
pas vous mettez votre main là je
découvre ça avec vous mais j'avais
demandé à ce qu on ne filme pas le dr ce
moment là pour pas qu'on pense qu'il ya
un écran de retour que je puisse voir ou
aux caisses c'est ça c'est ça c'est
toujours compliqué un jallet communiqué
portant là dessus avec le real c'est bon
c'est bon ok si je me retourne je ne
risque pas de voir quelque chose en
d'accord ok est ce que vous pouvez me
dire une qualité et un défaut qu'à cette
personne s'il vous plaît ah non mais
j'ai pas pensé
d'après vous cette personne qui à ce
signe alors eh quoi comme des connais
plusieurs personnes
alors non mais c'est très compliqué ce
que
vous voyez comment je suis assistant
alors que lui a complètement relâché je
vous explique pourquoi en fait c'est un
petit peu comme un match de tennis c'est
à dire que lui celle là c'est lui qui a
la balle moi je sais pas comment je vais
la rattraper sa balle et comment je vais
la resservir mais il faut qu'ils me la
renvoie pour que je puisse faire quelque
chose et là le problème c'est tranquille
d'idées je sais pas non mais là c'est
trop compliqué non mais on laisse tomber
je peux rien faire il faut qu ils me
renvoient la balle et après je ferai ma
popote en fait je me débrouillerai je me
tromperais dans le signe ou pas peu
importe ce qui se passera quelque chose
pour que j'avance c'est pas long vous
avez vu c'est que quelques secondes ces
10 secondes mais pour moi c'est une
éternité
orageux d'accord et un défaut à défaut
défaut
déchets dépasser une personne
je dirais que spontanément quelqu'un qui
ne sait pas quoi prendre qui ne sais pas
quoi dire pour un signe astrologique et
qui va me dire tout de suite courageux
c'est qu'ils pensent à un signe très
fort comme on va dire plutôt le taureau
le lion et je pense que c'est lyon il y
aura effectivement ce qu'on peut faire
un gros plan alors là vous avez entendu
tu le lis tu peux leur maître
effectivement il dit le lion ya léa
salamé qui dit oh [ __ ] qui équipe le
fait ce qu'on voit bien que le reste
n'est pas bluffer en fait là par exemple
si vous voyez le visage de laurent
ruquier n'est pas sur un visage de
quelqu'un de détonner hier que la
déconcentration du moment fait qu'ils
voient même pas que away avec un
adjectif il a quand même réussi à
trouver le signe par rapport à
l'ambiance qui avait versé pas rien
d'avoir fait ça est juste les actes qui
étaient concentrées elles ça la marque
et les autres salles et ça les impacts
pas ça ce mois pour le coup ça m'a pacte
beaucoup à ce moment là
caméra dans ses intonations voilà il est
là c'est le lion voilà et baisser des
intonations de c'est quoi la suite s'il
vous plaît maintenant jeune homme s'est
pas la suite c'est ça l'effet je viens
de vous tromper quand même et regardez
on voit la tête de thomas la tête de
tout le monde en fait on est sur une
attente de la suite ce moment n'a pas
été marqué pour les autres est ce qu'on
peut
je pense à léon javelot et là on dit et
là c'est quand même fou thomas n'ont
hélas thomas à cette phrase qui me gifle
et fort oui moi je pense à un lyon aussi
donc j'attends de voir la suite et je
vais dix mois au lie c'est pas qu'ils me
savonne la planche et que juriste de
glisser ses qui vient de m'enlever la
planche il ya plus de
plonger au milieu de l'océan et puis le
bon vous voyez un gamin comme ça etc on
est sûr de la fatigue de
désintéressement commence à se faire
sentir
et même les ac était quand même hyper
avec moi depuis le départ du coup ça
n'impacte elle aussi et vous avez vu là
son visage à l'instance qui peut refaire
un implant dessus stop les loïc ont fait
bon mais il ya le prénom quand même
maintenant je les perds ce que j'ai
pensé à ça m
c'est pas d'être la seule personne de
tout ce plateau c'est jacques qu'il l'a
vu c'est ce que je t'ai demandé de
regarder loïc et c'est là où jacques va
nous répondre
[Rires]
et prénom vous pensiez
c'est là que tout tout tout se joue pour
moi tout ce que vous avez vu ces heures
d'attentes cette solitude ce sentiment
de passer pour un guignol ambrée 1
malgré la sympathie
réel de laurent ruquier de léa salamé
tout se joue maintenant je me dis là
c'est là où je ferais l'adhésion ou pas
du public 2e de toutes les personnes
présentes au plateau
[Applaudissements]
peut-être tu peux remettre le moment de
la révélation loïc âge exact on finira
bien ce moment-là
il assez incroyable regardez tout ce qui
se passe pourtant jacques souvenait pas
que j'avais écrit à eux autant il m'a vu
écrire régis avant même de faire mon
effets de la fif est exact exact c'est
bien c'est bien ça
on essaye de reprendre le truc et tout
est et de la en plus si on voit léa
salamé qui est extrêmement bluffé
évidemment elle vient de choisir un
prénom dans sa tête je le trouve c'est
normal le sentiment est très fort pour
elle c'est ya ya pas de souci donc les
autres qui ce 10 mai à temps mais dû
pousser forme parce qu'il fait et là
regardez le plan revient sur moi
[Rires]
jacques a déjà la main sur mon bras pour
me faire taire parce qu'il a des choses
à dire d'accord
c'était la fois géniale est à la fois ou
quoi et
là j'ai essayé de refaire ma promo moi
même vous avez vu parce que c'est
important encore une fois je suis là
pour ça aussi coin je suis là pour finir
de promouvoir la fin de ce spectacle
vraiment j'ai rendez vous avec
un utilitaire de radio france bien sûr
corps
de générer qui prend le relais c'est à
dire qu'en temps normal vous comprenez
bien à la fin de l'émission c'est là où
laurent wauquiez léa salamé aurait dû
refaire voir la fiche en parlant du
spectacle non au fini avec avec jacques
qui me qui me posent des questions pour
lundi prochain voilà vous avez eu
l'analyse de ce passage je viens d'en
pleurer de rire vraiment c'était c'était
c'était très galère et
et la faute à rien en fait la photo au
temps qui passe à l'heure tardive qui
arrive à tout le monde qu un petit peu
crevé un manque qui a un manque
d'attention sûrement le plus dur passage
que j'aurais fait en télévision à faire
du mentalisme parce qu'à tout moment je
me disais je n'aurai pas le temps
d'aller au bout où je vais foire et où
on va me couper ou ça va pas les bleus
fait penser quoi louis
baillot il ya un côté de ba en fait en
tout cas si tu m'aimes bien tu te dis à
yahia et en même temps tu vois qu'ils
veulent pas me mettre des bâtons dans
les roues et que tu sens que tu as pas
envie d'être à ma place que tu as envie
de zapper pour pas me voir souffrir tu
vois et et tu sens que je risque de ne
pas réussir surtout voiture donc pour
moi ce sera ce sera ma petite fierté
vous des j'espère que cette analyse là
elle vous aura plu n'oubliez pas du coup
a compris que la dernière du spectacle
pas si c'est pas complet d'ailleurs au
moment où vous voyez cette vidéo c'est
le 11 décembre au zénith de paris il
reste aussi de dates en tournée aux deux
ou trois dates en tournée je voulais
mais juste là l'écran au moment où je
vous parle
et puis on se retrouvera aussi pour un
show unique qui s'appelle matière grise
c'est par hasard le 31 décembre à 16
heures au grand point virgule à paris
attention c'est un show unique que
j'écris pour une seule fois donc il sera
joué qu'une seule fois le 31 décembre à
16 heures à paris tout mais rien dans la
description et moi je réussis un
spectacle donc je pars en création de
nouveaux spectacles de janvier à juin
dans toutes les petites villes en france
et les grosses villes mais toujours dans
des petits lieux si vous voulez qu'on se
retrouve pour voir ce processus là c'est
assez intéressant et ce sera que de
l'inédit prenez soin de vous je vous
mets deux autres analyse ici prochaine
vidéo c'est lundi prochain à très
bientôt ciao